so now we're going to have our panel
discussion on leaders everywhere and
Jeffrey lands castor is going to lead us
he's the emerging technologies
coordinator for the science and
engineering libraries here at Columbia
welcome to the panel discussion we know
that we are sitting between you and
lunch so hopefully this will be
entertaining this is also hopefully
going to be a bit of a safe space
discussion we just now realized maybe
part of being a leader is taking risks
so three of our bosses and numerous
other administrators are actually in the
room so hopefully we'll all have jobs
after this I think was the sentiment so
just a little bit of logistics about the
way the panel will go I've asked each of
the panelists to introduce themselves
using one slide in about two to three
minutes so we should run through those
fairly quickly I've got a list of about
five or six questions that i want to ask
that will hopefully get the discussion
going and then we really want you to be
involved and so throughout the comments
we hope that you will be thinking about
questions that you might have we will be
responding to some of what was said
earlier in the day and then also
bringing up some other issues so please
feel free either to circle back around
to something that you heard earlier this
morning or to bring up your own
questions if we haven't touched upon
something that you're particularly
interested in and so that will carry us
through to lunch and then we'll get
everybody fed so with that if this goes
which it should I'm Karen oh that's me
I'm up high first thanks for having me
here so I was a college dropout at 18
and then I became a bartender because
this is what you do I was a bartender
for 15 years and it taught me a lot it
taught me how to handle difficult people
it taught me how to disagree while
smiling
I was listening this morning and then I
went back to school and I majored in
Medieval and Renaissance Studies at NYU
and I got a full fellowship to come here
to Columbia to do a PhD in medieval
history which I did not complete you
know it's kind of trend here but I also
was a comics fan my whole life and I I
put up the Bayeux Tapestry is kind of
the bridge between those two things
because if you think about medieval
visual culture then you see it's
sequential visual narrative so I became
the librarian for ancient and medieval
history here at Columbia in 2002 I
realized that we didn't have comic books
or graphic novels in the library in 2004
we had three actually mouse Persepolis
and Palestine they were all on reserve
and I thought oh we should maybe have
those and it was to a certain extent
driven by enlightened self-interest I
wanted to be able to check graphic
novels at a library instead of paying
for them because I'm a librarian and so
I don't make a lot of money but but
there were other reasons that which were
the ones that I actually use to pitch
this and now we have many many that's
just one little tiny tiny fraction of
the bookshelves we have over 4,200
titles now in the collection in many
many languages thank you to my global
studies colleagues for that and in 2010
i expanded my role in to create
collecting creator archives that's a
picture of Dennis kitchens archives in
his in his home in northampton
massachusetts how am i doing on time
degree excellent okay next okay so I'm
Stephen Francoeur I'm a user experience
librarian at Burke college before as a
librarian who worked in book publishing
and then as a development officer and
fundraising so this is my third career
and someone I'm going to stick with for
ever and ever I started library school
in 99 at Pratt and got an internship at
Baruch
and I've been at Brooke ever since I
started off in information services and
I was there for about 10 years working
in reference and instruction and one of
the early projects I got tapped to work
on was to help launch a chat reference
service at our college and it was a
whole ton of fun to get that up and
running and then expand it to share with
other service with other CUNY libraries
and give me a lot of experience working
not just with our own users but users
around the around the United States this
is the question point cooperative
service in the midst of all this work
doing reference and instruction I was
asked to serve on a web redesign
committee and general if you ask people
about what their experience was like
little grimace and usually run away web
redesign committees can be really
painful everyone's got an agenda I want
this I want that and they're bitter
battles but I was really engaged by it
and learned a little bit from our web
coordinator about usability testing and
I was a nice marriage of my interests in
working directly with users and trying
to take that knowledge to adjust systems
and tweak them and make them align
better with our users expectations so in
2010 11 my chief librarian who tort of
an annual review asked me what you want
to do with your career where which what
things would you like to be doing and I
thought back on my experience
redesigning the website and doing
usability testing and realize that that
was where some real interest was and
taking that deep knowledge of who our
users are and trying to translate that
into better services and resources for
for our college so I had to work with
him to create a new position and that's
where I've been since 2011 as a UX
librarian I shifted out of information
services over into collection management
and part of the bargain of moving to
collection management was that I would
help out with management of electronic
resources which was nice because then
to take my UX insights and start
tweaking our endlessly all the different
interfaces that we have access to for
this database and that discovery tool in
the catalog and the list goes on and on
so I'm Kelly and I wear a lot of hats I
thought I could start this presentation
off i can tell you very briefly about
what i do right now along with my actual
titles but i also wanted to kind of give
you a visual display of the stuff that i
really do day to day so i'm the
associate director for public services
at the center for science and social
science information at yale university
it's a hybrid organization between
university i TS and the library and the
first type of hybrid organization to
work in the system so it actually
presents a lot of different
opportunities to work with two very
different cultures within the university
so i thought i would start off with a
picture of me and a witch's hat which
actually represents a one of my favorite
parts of being a leader and a manager
and that's working with so many
different colleagues both as my
supervisors as my peers and also with
the staff who actually report to me this
was actually an initiative that was
suggested by one of my peers in the
center where i work we have LCD screens
where we post on hours workshops and
then also pages of all of the librarians
with pictures contact information and
we're goals that represent the different
tests or functions that we do so for
Halloween we kind of dress this up a
little bit that's the witch's hat and we
made were dolls kind of off of what we
usually have on them the different tasks
so I had access services the axe
interlibrary loan we had yeah they do
instruction and reference spells so that
was that's a really fun creative part of
my job that I enjoy a lot um I also get
to make sure that toilets are working
another part of being a man
really fun part um a whiteboard is up in
the top left and the whiteboard we get a
lot of feedback from our students
telling us what they'd like so again
part of being a leader leader and a
manager is making sure that we're
responding to what our users want so for
example they told us that they wanted
more study tables and shares in the
lower level also whiteboards so we made
sure that those kinds of things you know
ended up happening as a result of the
input that they gave us I also helped to
arrange game nights bottom left there we
have game nights at the end of every
semester we have a really large LCD
screen and we get a lot of pizza and
students come in it's very popular we
have grad students from the School of
Forestry and environmental studies who
have a very competitive spirit and they
love dance dance revolution so it's very
cute um I get to issue a lot of golden
stars and public accolades from all of
the great work that the center does
occasionally a demerit or two but not
very often and then the kind of center
picture is what I really feel that I
have to do a lot of in my job so I can
be kind of up there on the top some days
I can be balancing in the middle other
days and at the bottom sometimes I feel
like I'm holding a lot of things
together in a nice little balance the
picture of the supermom down here that's
a card that my teenage son made for me
about six years ago and I keep that
posted just because it's really
important for me to be a leader and a
manager in the house too and it also
just kind of helps me to feel better at
work when I'm having a tough day as a
leader and a manager so super moms thank
you mm-hmm so I wanted to just take a
brief second to talk about this question
of emerging technologies coordinator and
what it means star mention that I got my
PhD in chemistry about two and a half
years ago and then transitioned into the
libraries so I actually want to use this
as an example of kind of some of the
challenges that we've been facing so i
came in and i started with all these
great ideas right and i wanted
to do all of these different things and
so I got to do some of those ideas
initially and then after a while we
needed to start writing maybe a two page
description of that idea in order to
send it up the chain and have it get
approval and come back down and so said
okay and I started doing that and then
after a while we said okay well we're
doing a lot of these how do they fit
together and what's the picture that
you're actually trying to build from
doing all of this stuff so I wanted to
share that picture with you what we're
finding is that emerging technologies as
we're approaching them are falling into
three areas one is professional
development one is new modes of research
and one is outreach and so then on top
of this are all of these other things
that were sort of starting out as ideas
which then are growing into something of
like a strategic plan or what was it as
a strategic thinking and design which I
kind of liked for how we how we proceed
with a lot of this so we're doing a
number of different things looking at
how to support researchers and what they
do everything from teaching researchers
how to code and what good practices
around code looking at researchers who
share code and share data and making
them examples to then use them to then
encourage other researchers to do things
like that bringing in new physical
technologies everything from Arduinos
and open-source hardware 3d printing
hopefully some gaming technologies
things like that so a lot of this is
still sort of in the proposal phase some
of this has actually happened but I just
sort of wanted to give you an idea of
what my really cool job title actually
entails so jumping into things I
surprisingly I didn't know what order we
were going to be in and I got us in the
right order which is kind of great and
I'm
we have we have one dress out to be I
was worried I was gonna do the same
thing so to jump into this I was I was
at a conference last week in the week
before and there was an investor there
who said that he wanted to invest sixty
thousand dollars into a company and his
advisors were telling him to do this
$300,000 feasibility study before he
invested sixty thousand dollars into it
he said that doesn't make sense he said
you know I'd rather invest the sixty
thousand dollars and fail and get a fact
then spend a lot more money to sort of
know what's going to happen so I wanted
to touch on this question of leaders as
change agents leaders as people who are
willing to step outside of maybe the way
that things are normally done to try
doing something a different way and
maybe you can each sort of talk about a
time when you had to step outside of the
way that things were normally done in
order to accomplish something maybe that
was an idea maybe it was something that
you thought needed to happen for the
betterment of the organization yeah okay
I can do that okay so I mean I covered
that a little bit in my introduction I
was the librarian for ancient and
medieval history i'm still the librarian
for ancient and medieval history but in
2005 I proposed this initiative that we
collect graphic novels in the library
and I brought together a lot of people
actually who are still in this room I
brought together the fine arts librarian
the American Studies librarian the rare
books librarian our assistant head of
collection development and my supervisor
the director of the history and
humanities divisions but what I did
before I brought everyone together was I
met with everybody individually to sound
them out because you know that thing
they say about trial lawyers you're
never supposed to ask a question you
don't already know the answer to but
that was my feeling about going into
this meeting I wanted to make sure that
everybody was that I wasn't gonna get
sabotaged by a lot of people kind of
throwing tomatoes at me and it it wasn't
necessarily seen as an obvious
development but nobody had an objection
to it I guess you'd say
and I definitely never thought that it
would become as focal a an element of my
work as it is now but I think that just
asking you know all they can do is say
no just asking and I received ask and
you shall receive it worked that's a
good that's a really good strategy one
of the things I wanted us to touch on
are sort of strategies so the one is
bringing people together around the idea
and sort of making sure to establish
those connections beforehand and you
might get some pushback at some point
along the road and I'm sure you have no
this is the most incredibly supportive
institution you can imagine I have
literally had nothing but encouragement
and support for these last eight years
it's amazing Steven have at a time so we
started our chat service in 2001 it was
just a local service and in that time
that was that when the very first chat
reference cooperatives were being formed
and a cooperative base in California
came up with this great idea that
wouldn't be cool if we could do this
around the clock we would staff get
people that could work at three in the
morning five in the morning Thanksgiving
Christmas and the libraries are part of
the cooperative could get 24-7 coverage
and there was a lot of push back saying
well what's the point who's ever on you
know we can see you know people are
getting service people are coming in
between 10 and two or two and four and
that's all well and good why bother and
so well we'll never know what kind of
traffic will get unless we just open it
up so with the help of the chief
librarian we sort of decided to pitch it
as a pilot and that's with Elliot
mentions the best advice we everything
gets pitched as a pilot and 12 years
later we're still doing this hi of all
this points a finger at pilot but it
took a lot of experimenting and sharing
of the of the data from actual usage of
the services say no look it really is
worth it and it's an incredible bang for
the buck and it was a economic
proposition at the time
Burke had two staff to service eight
hours a week and the other 160 hours
were getting covered by other librarians
around the country and the quality of
the service was good enough especially
for three in the morning was good enough
that we could live with the fact that
the people helping our burg students
weren't necessarily experts in all the
policies and procedures of our library
but it did a lot of work to continually
share that the data and also start to
just do lots of presentations and
outreach to not just in group but then
across CUNY because then I also wanted
to get other CUNY libraries to join us
in our subscription by sharing a
subscription the price would go down so
we had a great incentive plus I wanted
you know I thought it was such a magical
thing to have chat reference I really
wanted to share this with all the other
kidney libraries and every chance like I
could I tried to help advocate for the
the great value of the service that with
a minimal weekly contribution you get
this incredible return and over time you
know we got up to seven or eight
libraries sharing our subscription and
our price just continue to go down but
it was a lot of pushback and resistance
had to be overcome and I think part of
that was starting with a really good
question you know how will we know what
the answer is you know and that idea of
experimental tea was brought up earlier
div yes yeah I don't um so about seven
years or so ago we decided to do away
with our reference desk and have just a
combined service point the information
desk and while I think most library is
like most libraries have that kind of
model or some permutation of it that was
kind of a big deal at Yale seven years
ago so I think we had about six
different reference tests that were
operating in different subject libraries
and at that point it was just the social
social science libraries before the
actual on combined library happen or the
combined Center and so we had had
different discussions with the
librarians there and there was some
pushback from some of the librarians who
had been there for quite a few years
but we gave them ample time to
understand that this change was
happening still there was some kind of
feet dragging through the sand but one
day we just decided the desk is going
and so we literally took the desk my
supervisor and I and put it behind a
concrete wall luckily enough we did put
it behind a concrete wall even though we
couldn't get facilities there to pick it
up but we just said you know we've got
to do this it's never going to be an
easier time so we did it and our
circulation staff were properly trained
and we moved over to the model and it
was fantastic the librarians I think you
know a year later once they looked at
their statistics and saw that the number
of consultations that they were getting
from the patrons I think quadrupled it
was you know deemed a success but it was
really really difficult very painful
going through it so sometimes you just
have to pull the trigger right you build
that desk and then you move the desk and
take it out piece by piece so that
nobody notices Thanks actually um the
next question that I want to ask has to
do with barriers and both the types of
barriers that you've encountered either
when you've been trying to lead or
trying to enact change how you've
overcome those and maybe if there's been
a time where you've had to stand down
because of a barrier so whether there
was something that you came up against
that you said you know right now is not
the best time maybe we'll come back and
visit this later but we'll put our
energy somewhere else does that
resonates even yeah I can speak to a
little bit one of my areas of interest
is scholarly communication and trying to
advance interest in open access
publishing and among my colleagues as
well as of course the broader college
but among my colleagues I think many of
them are very much on board and there's
a number of things that a library can do
we can as a department decide that we
will change our own will you know issue
a resolution supporting open access and
do something that it's ultimately just a
statement of
this is a cool thing to do but I really
wanted to get us to think about our
tenure and promotion guidelines and that
is like a real third rail of most
academic discussions about changing
those in a meaningful way and one of the
things I think that will really help
advance open-access efforts is when
tenure promotion takes into account open
access efforts and supports those and
maybe gives a gold star for those who
seriously engage with it in their own
publication efforts we don't have a
mandate for open access at brew core let
alone CUNY to be great if we did so at
the very least I feel like we can be
pushing our own tenure and promotion the
committee's to rethink that and I've
sensed my own colleagues that they were
kind of on board with that they kind of
saw that but they said but the rest of
the faculty they're not ready for that
yet they're going to freak out you know
if we start talking about like you know
bonus points for for publishing in a
gold open access journal or taking the
time to put all your works in the
repository and it said just wait like
we're not there yet to go there but and
so it wasn't a time I had to stand down
it because it was just me there's a few
other people that were probably as fired
up about it but in the you know I need
to be doing more bridge building across
the across the campus I think if I
really want to get this to go any
further so you haven't totally stopped
doing it you just re strategized maybe
and sort of pivoted and manipulated the
way that you did it into a different way
instead of its building that coalition
again this dog there's also a
technological issue too is that we don't
have an institutional or kuna watu
institutional repository yet it's coming
it's been coming for a long time if the
I won't get into uni politics but it's
it's not the library that's that's
holding up the boat but it we've been
waiting for it so it's a little hard to
advocate for to tell CUNY faculty oh we
really should do this when we don't have
a good place for them to deposit their
own materials and we can say you can put
it in the subject repository or here
there but we really need to have our own
for that so that also is something we
need to take care of first overcoming or
I could say that there haven't been a
lot of barriers within the libraries I'm
almost I was I was confused when I was
asked to be on this panel because I
don't really think of myself as a leader
but it's true that my own kind of
irrational exuberance and my self
promotion have have caused Columbia to
be seen as a leader in collecting in
kind of respecting comics and respecting
the history of this of this medium in
this industry even though we're not only
not the first academic library to
collect but we're not even the first Ivy
League library to collect Yale had a
collection long before ours and any
effectiveness I've had has really been
by developing this incredibly broad
network of connections with with
cartoonists with publishers with other
scholars with other librarians with
cultural institutions with arts schools
etc but the one real barrier I had I've
had is trying to get deeper penetration
into the academic departments on this
campus not so much in using the
collection when I when I started it I
wasn't aware of anybody who was actually
teaching with comics and gradually you
know some of these faculty kind of came
out of the closet and two years ago we
had the first course taught by tenured
faculty dedicated to the history of the
American graphic novel which couldn't
have been taught if this collection
didn't already exist but I have
cartoonists incredible teachers some who
are teaching at Harvard somewhere
teaching MIT we were saying you know hey
I live in
you're can Columbia again me how can I
do a workshop can I do of course really
gifted teachers but the barrier I've
encountered is dealing with the academic
departments and getting them to take
that notion seriously and I've yet to
succeed at that sure I'm going to go in
a little bit of a different direction
though in my answer and it's a little
bit more personal when I got into
librarianship I was very very lucky to
have very early mentors that saw
leadership potential and said let's go
tiger and so maybe because I'm outgoing
I jumped on the opportunity but blessed
with jeans I looked very very young when
i first started so i encounter
encountered some ageism and it was
difficult to overcome because i did have
fantastic mentors who were just really
you know trying to get me in to give me
great opportunities that a lot of the
librarians who had been there for a much
longer time that I had been there
weren't having and so it was difficult
and so when I was given and given an
opportunity to be put in an interim head
position for a little while I actually
had colleagues say to me you know face
to face it's not fair because you don't
have the experience because you're not
old enough and so that was really
difficult to encounter so I had to
realize that while I felt like I was
ready and you know on an energetic kind
of level to take the bull by the horns
and use those opportunities to move
forward in my career that I really had
to take a few steps back and move a lot
more slowly you know them what I kind of
them what my mentors felt that I needed
to but just so that I could work a lot
more collaboratively and get more buy-in
from the staff that I was you know had
been working at a peer level with
but then going to an interim department
head levels so that's kind of a more
personal take to that question but it
was a barrier and then a huge learning
experience that's really served me well
absolutely I've got one more question
but if people wanted to if you do have
questions that you've come up with if
you want it to go ahead and start making
your way to the microphones that'll give
us an idea of you know how much time to
a lot for questions so if you do have
questions go ahead and start your way
there the last question I wanted to ask
is sort of about institutional culture
and where you see that coming from does
it come from the top does it come from
the bottom does it come from the Middle
where in your institution in your
organization does the support for
leadership scum do you have support to
develop as a leader what has been your
experience is it isn't top down bottom
battlin first on this I'll take it so
I've been at Yale for eight and a half
years now and it's a complex to say the
least organization and I've had several
supervisors we've had different
University librarians we've had
different a ul's and I have to say that
our culture has changed based on each of
those people coming in so I can't really
say that there's an overall culture that
we've seen you know a shift from this
person leaving to the next person but
you can really see those changes in
cultures at all level I mean the culture
in the department unit area that I work
in is very very different in terms of
support for developing you know and
providing leadership and management
opportunities then say unit X you know
or even at the UL aul level so it's very
very different and I couldn't I mean if
somebody were to ask me what's the
culture of your organization i would say
give me the day of the week you know and
I can tell you and that might be
something that's important for people in
a leadership role to hear and to
understand that you know and maybe to
ask themselves do you want to have an
organizational culture and what will
that culture be when somebody at another
part of the organization is asked that
question I mean that's something that I
think a lot of heads of libraries ought
to be thinking about and then it's a
question of how do you then implement
that do you want to go second here yeah
um okay let me think this through as I
stare into Damon's eyes your mouth for a
little while um I think we didn't I
think that Columbia libraries have have
evolved into more no that's not true I
think that well I'm just thinking of our
previous University Librarian which was
very top down I think it was just top it
was this just top I don't think there
was any down but I think that we are to
a certain extent still a very top-down
organization but I also feel that
individual people here have been able to
reach into that structure and make
suggestions and give feedback and you
know I really feel like my own
trajectory here is is evidence of that
to reinvent themselves reinvent their
departments I'll of librarianship for
that facility to allow reinvention which
i think is not a quality in a lot of
professions so I think that if if people
are willing to take the initiative to
kind of infiltrate that top-down
structure they can still affect change
but I think primarily I think most
people see it as a top-down structure do
you want to bridge that with the CUNY
system oh uh yeah well I can't really
speak as well to the CUNY system because
it's a odd creature it's such a it's a
loose Federation so the
but and what's also quite different
about my experience from my fellow
panelists is that Burke is a tiny
institution relative to Columbia and
Yale we have 23 24 librarians total it's
an extremely flat organization so it's
kind of hard for me to characterize the
organizational culture because it just
seems so small there's a chief librarian
there's five division heads and then a
whole bunch of librarians so there is a
lot of direction that comes from the top
the chief librarian is very encouraging
about wanted to try new things to be
innovative I don't know how he finds
funding for all the various technologies
that we're able to get but he does it
help cities also the CIO so that helps
steer some money our way but a lot of
the initiative does come from the
individual librarians is teaming up
together it's a less formal organization
so maybe we can get away with more of
that so colleague and I just decided to
have a biweekly or twice a month and
remember bi-weekly is the same as
bimonthly seminar like a brown bag
technology workshop thing it was a great
way to get everyone talking about stuff
is also greg was the chief librarian
would come and we could pick his brain
or sudden like okay like can you tell us
about this thing you mentioned and but
there's a lot of sort of wool efforts
that just start up like a couple
librarians team up together they pitched
their idea to the chief librarian he
asked a whole ton of really tough
critical questions and it's good because
it really makes you think stuff through
her before he says yes so I'd say that
we are generally pretty open to
innovation but a lot of it it's on us to
come up with those projects which it can
be a barrier to because you know you
have to sometimes it's nice to get
nudged a little it's easy to get set in
your ways and think like oh I don't need
to worry about that that sort of project
or that technology and wait for someone
else to tell you to start doing
something or it might be our instruction
program like we really need
change how we do assessment in and
assess overall or information literacy
program or so it does take a lot of
individual initiative to get things
going at a small organization I think
but don't you think that also makes you
more nimble I mean it's a little bit
like Elliott's clipper ships right you
know a smaller institution is going to
be able to turn away from those rocks
perhaps faster than the big six master
and so I gear I troops the only place
I've ever only only library ever worked
at so I went to Columbia library is
called a battleship you know we turn
very slowly so I don't see anybody
standing up for questions quite yet if
you want to please go ahead otherwise
I'm just going to keep going I was a kid
whose dad read him Stephen Covey's 7
habits of highly effective people as a
bedtime but that tells you anything and
these other like weird human resources
like I'm sure some of the ones you know
that we heard about earlier if that had
been around then so a short question but
maybe a complicated answer do you each
think of yourself as a leader I already
answered that so you said no I said I
don't yeah I think Columbia is seen as a
leader because of things that I've done
but I don't see you know nobody reports
to me I I'm not I don't know I I have a
high profile but I don't know that that
is equivalent to being a leader people
know who I am but that doesn't mean
people are necessarily following you
know dancing to the tune I'd pipe yeah
that's interesting yeah Stephen for
whatever for whatever it's worth I think
i have like if i have any sort of regard
from others as a leader it's just
because my online presence i'm not sure
how much of an influence i've had in my
own institution or in CUNY per se maybe
a little bit with a chat reference and
CUNY but for me like I feel like I've
really carved out a space for myself by
being online
and I have to give credit back when I
was library schooled in 1999 to
stumbling on Steven bells kept up
librarian website where he advocated all
these techniques for staying on top of
and first he said it's really important
to stay on top of things outside of the
library world as well as within and so I
quickly established my own little
beachhead online about digital reference
services and it amazed me of how much of
a you know I still to this day don't
understand quite how that little website
became at that had on digital reference
the teaching librarian became something
pega so I was there early on digital
reference so that did help but feel the
need yeah i mean that's yeah but it led
to so many things like our invitations
to write articles to speak and so I put
a lot of work into it and over the years
I've sort of expanded all the things I
do online blogging and have a little
commonplace book we're all this stuff
that I read and my blog or in my feed
reader I try to take little snippets and
share it back but it's amazing what how
that network effect can really play out
and I bump into people all the time I
have friends around the world who were
librarians and for me that's probably
the most rewarding thing I've gotten as
a librarian as I can go to a la or a crl
and bump into people I've never met
before but they've known me for years
online and so I guess in that sense I
feel like I'm I'm leading just by I'm
not coming up with new ideas I'm just
sharing stuff that I thought was cool
but that seems to have fill a need it's
a very librarian thing to curate for
other people so that fits in that
actually I just made me think I actually
I wrote an online column for four and a
half years every month about using
comics in academia and that got a lot of
recognition that led to you know
becoming a member of the board of
trustees at the Museum of comic and
cartoon art and then on the board of
directors to society of illustrators a
judge at the eyes nurs you know because
it raised the profile i think that
online presence can't be under estimate
estimated it makes an enormous
difference yeah sorry that's all I want
to say oh yeah oh yeah um so I would
have said prior to about two and a half
weeks ago that I lead projects but then
oddly enough i can't remember i think it
was Elliot that brought up 360 feedback
sorry if I'm not appropriating that to
the right person but I just went through
360 feedback at exceptional leaders
training at Yale a couple of weeks ago
so I guess as a result of that I would
now claim that I'm a leader and not just
because I attended leaders training but
more because of the feedback that I
received from my peers and the people
that I work with it was clear that a lot
of people do perceive me as a leader
which was great and it is made me really
think about my role and kind of claiming
that word too in the context of what I
do so that's kind of a literal yeah
owning it is very very important so
it'll actually chip cookies I want to
add him one more thing about I was just
thinking about the being online I I
think one thing that really i have to
mention is like just the value of
networking outside of your institution
and I you know over the years like for
example Metro has been a huge influence
on me and I first by participating in
various cigs and then I was the the
co-chair of the virtual reference sing
for a long time but at the relationships
I formed with librarians all around the
city and from the school librarians the
public librarians the medical librarians
I would never have bumped into learn so
much from them and so like all the stuff
online it's not just like I want to
share so if I want to learn stuff but
the the networking locally too has been
an immensely powerful thing for me we
were completely blessed being here in
New York City by having so many
different librarians to hang out with
and learn from so that's an other really
thing that can help with a whole lot of
barriers as well like just being able to
mean if you're in a small college town
in North Dakota and there's no other
libraries nearby you really have to work
hard on your online presence but here
we've got both the online opportunities
but the fifth the local stuff as well I
think it's really important to think of
yourself as part of a network i once
called myself a node in that Network and
Jim Neal made fun of me for it so I was
like I'll take it anyway yeah so over
here hi um my name is Nick Groff time
from the edge of cope institute and my
question is I'm a fairly recent graduate
from library school what do you think is
a role of library school in nurture
aiding nurturing or cultivating an
attitude that gets you ready to take
some leadership anybody wanna yeah 30
library school instructors in the
audience I i didn't i didn't go to
library school i do work with a lot of
students who are in library school
though and i think that's really
interesting because i think they're
coming and working with me and getting
skills you know at a first level that
they're not going to get in library
schools that i think is kind of
interesting i think your question is a
good one about fostering that leadership
mentality and I think it really is I
mean from what you know we've heard it's
a mentality right and I think it's
something that some people are going to
be drawn to other people will be forced
into and some people might never
encounter it I don't know if you would
ever see like a leadership class you
know in library school you know by all
means start one and teach one if you're
really interested in it that I think
what do you guys think for me it was all
about a personal relationship I had as a
research assistant to Murray Radford and
she was at Pratt I learned so much from
her just watching what she did I had no
clue i've never been in academia before
had no clue how it worked I knew I want
to wind up in academic library so
she was a great proxy for the working
life of an academic watching how she
prepared for conferences and
presentations and publications she was
doing and inviting me to help her so
that sort of even though I was doing
work for it wasn't photocopying or
tedious opposed doing real research for
and helping her out and that was hugely
helpful for me that sort of informal
mentorship I'm not sure I took a library
management class and I can see that my
instructor from 12 years ago was not
here it was not at all helpful and I'm
not sure I honestly I think it's more of
the informal mentoring that goes on that
may be better than any sort of formal
programs but I don't know I'm not of i
think given that much thought to library
school I was in library school while I
was working here as a supervisor I was
running the course reserves department
which is a wonderful place to work for
your first job in a library because you
deal with catalogers and reference
librarians and acquisitions and faculty
I mean you're really kind of your a node
at the center of a lot of different
elements of the library and i have to
say i went to Rutgers and I found it
tiresome beyond belief I found it very
heavily theoretical and and almost not
at all practical I didn't feel I learned
anything practical in library school I
felt that it's it was a socializing
process and it made me feel like I was
part of a profession and I think that
that's an important thing and now when I
sit on search committees I have to tell
you I still look for that MLS on
people's especially if it's if it's a
recent PhD who's applying for a library
job no offense Jeffrey I I want to know
that they're committed to being a
librarian and that MLS is one of those
pieces of evidence that indicates it so
that's that's what sorry everybody
that's what library school is for me
okay so I'd like to say two things about
that I was very fortunate in library
school I had fantastic mentors that
actually gave me a lot of hands-on
experience that told me you know i need
to do a new cordless in women's studies
on you know technology for example that
the women's studies library and was
responsible for and she said go do it
yeah university of arizona sorry um so I
did and she went you know through it
with me at the end of the project and
said you know okay this is the right
thing you should have done this is what
you overlooked you know and so it was a
real learning process for me the same
with teaching they actually let me go
out to their English classes and do
co-teaching with them and then at the
end of that internship I did some
teaching on my own and you know that's
where the final grade came from so I was
really fortunate that I got to do a lot
of that hands-on you know stuff as
graduate assistants assistant ship and
also as internships on because like you
the classes there wasn't a whole lot
there and I also don't think there's
anybody from University of Arizona I
mean that a question for you just is
that something you're hearing from
people in library school so your
classmates and library school were they
yearning for more leadership training um
I wouldn't say so we also had a
management requirement which was of
course one of the most hated classes and
it's just yeah I often hear this thing
of you know like I took leadership I led
like a student group or something it's
always like self motivated but to me if
you're paying all this money to this
organization to give you some sort of
stamp of approval I want to be getting
something back out of it and with
leadership being such an important
component and something is changing as a
library that to me should be a
responsibility that a library school
takes on but I don't know exactly how
they try and foster that to every
student that comes to they don't just
say yeah go take go take the initiative
and you know become a leader yourself
that is there some way for them to
out to the student and encourage them to
do that to develop those skills I mean
on the one hand you know maybe it's a
matter of fostering these mentorship
relationships where you don't quite know
what's going to come out the other end
of it but you can at least set up a
scenario where that's a possibility for
somebody and then sort of follow that
through and see where it goes I mean I
can't speak for any library school
administrators about what they should
shouldn't do that I've seen a lot of
interesting things going on at Metro
with library school students showing up
for either paid workshops or for the
free cigs special interest groups and
people that would come regularly and I
think the library schools in Metro like
that's an obvious point of connection
because they're especially the cigs
anyone can show up and learn about
something that's you know free to come
and basically everyone's welcome like if
you run a cig on any topic like you're
going to get people from all different
kinds of libraries but I would imagine
for library school students it's a great
place to hang out and ask the questions
and also get real practical experience
about what's going on in libraries
thanks um so one other thing is Cheryl
LaGuardia in the audience by any chance
did anybody see her library journal
column on professional development
yesterday so she did a poll it's
actually a really good article and I
printed it off because I figured there
might be something in here and it's
called professional development what's
it to you and she actually went about
asking both practitioners in the library
world and then also managers what their
definition of professional development
was and it's very very interesting
because it runs the gamut and but one
thing actually that was brought up about
library school students was that she
says or one of the quotes was honestly
anything that kids are learning in
library school / technologies is behind
they need to expand out to meetup groups
or take supplemental online courses the
rest of what this individual says is
very business school sounding
and so I thought that was very
interesting to kind of hear from a
manager's perspective you know what kind
of skill sets the librarians should have
coming out of library school and like I
said it really sounds like students
should be taking not just the library
management class that's required but
more you know a couple of other classes
electives in a business school to
diversify startups agile environments
those absolutely design thinking mmhmm
yeah go ahead hi I'm wondering if you
guys could speak to sort of managing and
leading through the effective dimensions
of change we've talked a lot about and
heard a lot about leadership as part of
steering your big ship and those in
terms of change and that comes with a
lot of really material bad effects like
people losing their jobs people having
to share offices that never had to share
them before people's jobs being
redefined re disk you know like all that
stuff is like wrenching so how do you
deal with the sort of pain that comes
from change it makes me think of when we
first started doing chat reference at
Baruch there were a number of librarians
that you know they're okay great let me
do the training and they sat down for
the first time and they heard the little
machines beeping at them in chiming and
they they tensed up and and one of the
the best reference librarians ever met
in my life who trained me and taught me
wonderful things I don't know if I've
learned them all but he tried to share
with me wonderful things he just was not
comfortable at all doing chat and
initially the plan was everyone was
going to do chat like we're gonna do
this it's important and then we realized
you know what there's no point pushing
on these he's just not going to be as
good of a chav librarian in chat which
is already pretty high stress mode to be
doing reference work because is a lot
missing that we've come to rely on for
doing reference work and so we've let
him opt out of it and there was there's
been a handful of people to we're like
okay you know what you we don't all have
to do this like let's be flexible and
and so there's a handful of people that
just have never done chat they decided
you know
data so I think you have to respect that
as well and not try to force everyone to
come along for the ride I think a lot
depends on on the people who are a level
above you I know here when we've had
change we've had often directors who are
incredibly skilled at I don't know
reframing the change perhaps making it
it sounds like I'm saying spinning it
and i don't mean spending it i mean
thinking through all of the elements
that are the consequences of that change
and what ones are positives that we can
emphasize and kind of fostering a
feeling of everybody still being in it
together and that is reassuring and it's
nice to be reassured you know we're all
still scared little kids inside I guess
so if you've got people above you who
are inflicting this change just
willy-nilly without thinking of the
consequences then yeah you're going to
have a lot of heartbreak and pain and
dissatisfaction and crankiness but if
you've got somebody who who can really
guide you through that and and kind of
foster a cohesive pneus in in the
organization well then you're pretty
lucky
should I bring up the dreaded reorg so
when I said that the center for science
and social science information is a
joint venture between university i TS
and the libraries it also combined two
different units being the science in the
social science libraries which had not
been combined before and because we were
all going to go into one physical
facility and we knew it was going to be
a rework there was a lot of there was a
lot of nervousness from staff thinking
but we don't we definitely don't need as
many staff to move into this combined
service as we currently have in two
different libraries so we really needed
to think and we did think very
creatively about how we could rethink
the jobs that we did need in a combined
service space without laying off people
and we ended up really I think doing a
good job in you know redefining these
job descriptions and appropriately
matching staff that had at least some of
those tasks you know things that they
were already able to do in their job
their their existing job descriptions
and transferring those skills into the
new job descriptions it ended up that we
didn't have to lay off as many people as
we thought we were going to have to lay
off and we just made sure that there
were a lot of conversations with staff
through the process so that's not saying
that it took away all of the bad stuff I
mean it was still incredibly hard for
everybody managers staff at all level
but I think it's just the key is really
good communication providing training
and making sure that you're going to
provide whatever you know the staff
needs to get through the bumpy parts
that helps that's the best note ever to
end a panel discussion on so thank you
all very much we hope you enjoyed the
panel will all be here throughout the
rest of the day I hope and so thank you
again
you